يعني الذهاب من مكان لمكان هو من اصعب
الاماكن والاشياء اللي احنا بنواجهها خلال
عملنا الصحفي التنقل من مكان لمكان هو صعب
جدا في غزه اليوم لانه الاحتلال لم يدخل
الوقود الى غزه طبعا ه الوسيله الوحيده
نطلع من مكان لمكان بنروح لاماكن العمل
الصحفي
و بنعمل تقاريرنا بتعمل كل اجوائنا في ظل
انعدام الوقود لسياراتنا الان اصبحت في
مكانها وبنقوم التنقل بهذه الطريقه على
الحصان او على
الكاره حتى نقوم ب يعني انجاز بعض
التقارير اللي بنحاول نصار لها خلال اي
خلال الفتره هذه العمل الصحفي هو شبه
متوقف لانه فقط عندي نص السياره بنزين بعد
هيك ما فيش اي كميه وقود ممكن اوفرها فبحر
على الامر الضروري جدا
فقط
احنا بالنسبه لنا شعور يعني احنا مش
مجربين